so apparently Jordan Peterson's trying
to counter the wef with his own
organization have you guys heard the
details of that yeah it's called The
Association of international polite
Canadians no no no no it's it's not it's
called something else I know
it no it sounds like great he wants to
get a bunch of intellectual and
governmental people together
and he's he said that every single place
he went to the the response was like
yeah we'll drop everything we'll join
with you
so uh Jordan Peterson proposes
alternative to World
economic economic Forum let me see what
I can find here the Deep dive proposes
WF alternative will be will he be the
new Klaus Schwab I don't I don't know
that I want Jordan Peterson leading some
[__] like opposing group to Klaus
Schwab he's just he's just like crazy on
the opposite side of the coin with some
of his views although he's better than
the [__] WF Davos crowd it's just
like is he actually completely better
like is he uh is he the antidote as he
likes to call himself you know
a lot of which a lot of psychologists
are like that doesn't take away
the heat adds a lot of value to the
space but uh he's kind of it's a little
unstable too you've all seen him break
down and cry or lose his stuff or he's
like oh I don't feel good and then he
disappears for a while
yeah and then his and then his views on
like you know marriage and the family
structure like he doesn't offer any real
solutions like this is his new outfit
here where he's got like it's almost
like a red pill blue pill suit where
it's like half and half
Jekyll and Hyde I don't know maybe
I don't know where this is going like I
really don't know where this is going
I'm gonna have to dive into it because I
watched uh Joe Rogan clip where he kind
of introduced the notion to some of the
talking points and most of them made
sense and would probably get support of
of like most guys out there but the
thing that
you know where he always loses me is
where he starts talking about
family units and marriage and stuff like
that and it's like dude until you change
the [__] laws it is an absolute
slaughterhouse and any guy with with
half a brain in his head would not
expose himself to that kind of risk ever
again right so when are we going to
propose a solution to that
well my view on him is you know it's
kind of the Reagan view if I agree with
70 of what what he says I I agree with
that I mean if I think 30 of what he
says is a bit crazy then then that's
that but he he completely and utterly
explains the whole [__] kid thing
um perfectly in that podcast with Rogan
and he was on number one of the activist
moms who had an uh a [__] kid and a
gay kid and he just said statistically
the chances of a one household having a
trans kid and a gay kid in it is like
seven million to one just some insane so
he said it's not the kids we should be
looking at under that roof it's the mom
yeah it's not it's not common obviously
um there's an at reply tweet here from
somebody said uh I've I've not looked in
the details but I'm against Global
groups of powerful people trying to
determine how the rest of us should live
and I fully agree with that you know
like anybody that's more libertarian
basically doesn't want to hear any of
this nonsense it is totally left alone
yeah say the [__] out of my life yeah
don't be a see you next Tuesday that's
it sometimes you're gonna have to band
together to be left alone
yeah I'm gonna have to dive in this to
see what it's all about and I don't know
maybe I'll maybe I'll dedicate a show or
an unplugged Alpha show on it and really
kind of like dig into it but
I mean you know he's
the thing with Jordan Peterson is for
every great idea that he's have
what the hell is that
uh someone someone's honking okay
is that like uh
this is a dynamic mic these are like the
angry wasps or something like the killer
one this Mike Norman doesn't pick up
background noise but yeah I must have
gotten it today that was crazy that was
like a big buzz but I mean like for
every three or four great ideas he's
he's got he's equally got like one or
two they're just like batshit crazy that
just are gonna
completely [__] up people's lives right
so he's a [__] 10 on the intelligence
scale yeah yeah yeah he's definitely
unstable that's for sure I don't know I
don't know I'll have to dive into it and
see what it's all about purple pill is
what Daniel says he is purple pilled and
God pilled maybe I don't know
yeah I'm starting to move away from all
those pill type definitions because it
seems like there's a lot of in groups
and out groups the subgroups within the
overall space which I know you call it
like the Mana swamp or the manosphere is
what it used to be called but I get
people that reach out to me all the time
like are you blue pill your red pill are
you this or that or it's like I don't
even use that language anymore just just
build an awesome just build an awesome
life like get it all together got
I've met up with your guys guys that
have come down here and stayed with me
like you kind of know what that looks
like and then you start to evolve away
from those those labels well it's
subject to interpretation and
everybody's going to label their [__]
pill with whatever you know problem it
ends up solving it's it's not a it's not
like you go to like it's not like you
buy a supplement and the ingredients are
always consistent in it it's you know
you open the bottle and you interpret
you know the pill to to solve this
problem whereas I open it and I
interpret it to solve that problem but
it's like you know the ingredients are
you know need to remain consistent if
you're going to label it that way that's
why this whole pill notion is just
[__] stupid and it's just you know
people making up you know pill colors to
identify with their
um you know with their ideologies it's
like stop it or you know keep doing it
because you sound stupid so
you want to know if somebody's dumb
they've got a color pill that they want
you to buy there's this white one this
purple one this green one there's a
buddy of mine in California a
photographer and he's one of these guys
I get on the phone and I don't get off
for an hour and a half because we
discussed Theory yesterday he mentioned
the book called thought reform not not
taught reform Paul okay
all the details on labeling on imagery
on all of that stuff used to
um use to control and it just you know
we me and him spoke about it for an hour
yesterday because he's just finished
reading and he gave me all the insights
into it and how people stifle
conversations silence people make people
paranoid get people to
you know get behind labels movements
everything it's like if you've ever read
the True Believer by Eric Hoffer on the
nature of mass movements they'll
describe mass movements but this this
book goes into the psychology of how to
get people thinking on mass
that's called thought reform
what do you guys think like
and we touched on this briefly but him
but him crying all the time like is
what's that about like he seems to cry
like I'll be honest like I will tear up
if I read somebody's email and they're
like
like the one email that made me tear out
more than anything was that uh Mexican
vet that basically said he was gonna jab
a horse tranquilizer dart in his leg and
he's like I didn't because of you know
some of the videos that I watched and
you know like your content like that
like that'll make you tear up but it
seems like every time somebody says
something that you know pulls on his
heartstrings he starts crying I don't
know if he's got a bad hormone panel or
if he's like like there's something
wrong with him but he cries a lot what's
up it sounds like it but I've told guys
that
um when you're because Rich you've
talked about using an aromatase
inhibitor or not and I I fell in I used
to always use one and then I got to the
point where like okay I can back off the
test a bit it actually keeps me a little
leaner too
um because with the estrogen the the
part that does aromatase it it holds it
holds more water and you get more of
that so so I keep my test maybe a little
a little down than what I used to run it
at just to uh reduce the water retention
and whatnot but I'll notice that if if
especially for guys on trt if your test
if it gets a little higher let's say
sometimes it's real hard in the syringe
to get it like exactly on there so
you'll get yeah you'll get a little bit
over but I always say that I can feel
like once you start out of nowhere start
getting like like an itchy nipple for a
couple seconds or you start tearing up
in a sad part in a movie where normally
you wouldn't care that's like all right
I should probably look at my estrogen
here um it's been years since I've had
that happen I've got that dialed in now
but I I think it probably does have to
do with something hormonally and I
actually had a guy reach out to me the
other day
so that the notion of men crying which I
get it especially growing up in the 90s
like oh men need to be sensitive yeah
it's all a bunch of nonsense but but I
think guys get confused sometimes I had
a guy reach out the other day and he's
like hey I'm going to my dad's funeral
and so is it okay to cry I'm like dude
of course it's okay to cry at a funeral
like what are you talking about but I've
noticed for me personally I I don't ever
cry at funerals when I'm sad I cry when
I'm happy for whatever reason like if
something just yeah amazing happens like
I'll start to tear up and I don't know
why I'm like okay like yeah yeah it's
like tears of joy not not really sadness
but
does anybody know if he's on trt like
has he ever announced has he said
anything I mean he doesn't look I mean
he's not out of shape he's very lean
like he's very thin he's on that all
neat diet it's nothing but me auto
autoimmune stuff right he's got the same
thing his daughter has
apparently what raging talk
I don't know I don't know how how so
many people people take her so seriously
I mean you know God bless her for
broadcasting and doing whatever she's
doing if it helps anybody but you know
the amount of people that look past your
past is just shocking too and you know
what was the big red flag when he first
came on the scene and he was like oh my
daughter's gotten you know she's on her
first picture of like was I'm getting
healthy and it was a snapshot of like it
was the first time I ever saw her on
social media and it was like oh I'm
getting healthy I'm back on track and it
was a picture it was a bikini shot and
I'm like that whoa whoa whoa I said
that's that's you know that's not what
you do when you're getting healthy
now you know unless you were 300 pounds
and you finally got into a bikini but
this was like here I need an excuse to
pause me in a bikini yeah yeah this is
about me half naked if you're 300 pounds
then you're getting a bikini you're
gonna have a loose skin issue which guys
that work with me they're like oh I have
100 pounds to lose you're like you gotta
you gotta take that into consideration
you're losing a lot of weight real quick
you're gonna have some loose skin and uh
women oftentimes get it worse than men
do actually yeah I really hope you guys
enjoyed that clip if you want to watch
the full length podcast you can find
that over here that clips from if you're
new to the channel make sure you hit
subscribe over here and pin down below
in the top comment you'll find a bunch
of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out